welcome back to New rockstars I'm Anna
vanston and I'm Tommy bechtold and we're
the current record holders for most
rehydrated beans found in the office and
I rehydrate them with my mouth everyone
knows that feeling of a you get when a
character says the title of a movie in
the movie and Martin movies of quite a
few of those moments yes but we wanted
to know which movie took the shortest
amount of time to say the title in which
movie took the longest so here's how
it's going to work if a movie says the
full title great we'll mark the time
they said if only part of the title is
said we'll go with whatever time the
most important part of the title is set
also the title has to be spoken it can't
be written you know new rock stars
doesn't take advantage of the fact that
Tommy and I are professional actors too
often so the flicks are acting muscles
and potentially avoid some copyright
issues we'll be doing a dramatic
reenactment of ones we thought just
could have used a little more je ne sais
quoi you know you speak French
starting with a classic I feel like
everyone knows they say Iron Man in the
film but it might be further along in
the movie than most people remember yes
Tony first says it while reading about
himself in the newspaper before his
press conference an hour and 50 three
minutes and 44 seconds into the movie
Iron Man that's kind of catchy it's got
a nice ring to that yeah I don't know if
that time's even gonna clear the top ten
but what about its sequel hmm Iron Man 2
says Iron Man right at the beginning of
the movie when Tony Stark's press
conference from the first movie he's
playing on the TV if it's from the first
movie is it cheating I don't care there
you have it so Iron Man 2 clocks in it
one minute in four seconds
[Music]
if they ever say specifically Iron Man 2
in the movie even if it's too like Tio
or t-o-o and they don't but they cut up
here's where we would have put it if we
were running things
Iron Man 3 also says Iron Man but
unfortunately not Iron Man 3 which is a
travesty here's what you could have had
Marvel Iron Man
and here's what they had 15 minutes and
59 seconds into the movie instead
cowards you know what happened when I
told people is Iron Man's bodyguard they
would laugh on my face Tommy I grow
weary of Iron Man I want to act then
there's only one series we can go to
it's Thor timing baby they say Thor's
name eight minutes and 53 seconds in
when Odin is giving a speech in which
he's about to Proclaim Thor King hey
where are you going oh boy oh
Odin son
my air
my firstborn
we are there of the mighty Hammer
mjolnir well we've got another Thor up
next and in Thor the Dark World they do
say Thor when a chained up Loki nice
it's talking to Odin five minutes and 55
seconds in and what a thought however
they also say the Dark World in this
movie even though it's much later 54
minutes and 39 seconds in I think we got
to count this one's time since it's such
a substantial part of the title it
happens was talking to Odin
[Music]
Odin I'll take Jane to the Dark World
draw the enemy away from ascot
so good at playing
the Thor train continues continues when
Thor's name is set 56 seconds into Thor
Ragnarok in the opening scene as Thor's
voiceover explains the situation he's in
like so now I know what you're thinking
oh no Thor's in a cage how did this
happen same situation though they do say
Ragnarok two minutes and 25 seconds in
when certa is sitting on a throne
talking to a chained up Thor
so we're counting that one yeah ass and
you have seen Ragnarok the fall of
Asgard as good as we are at embodying
Thor and Odin we're gonna leave cord to
the professionals and it's Korg that
says both the term Thor at seven minutes
and 32 seconds and love and thunder at 1
hour 48 minutes and 16 seconds your
lovely little voice over bookends to the
movie is Korg relates Thor's story roll
eclipse come get around and listen to
The Legend of the
aka the God of Thunder AKA Thor odinson
they have traveled far and have been
given many names
but to those who know them best they are
simply known as love and thunder gotta
count love and Thunders time for this
one now let's move along to our lovable
Black Sheep on the list ah The
Incredible Hulk where you saw Betty Ross
once and never again so many questions
so little time but the main question is
do they say the name of the title the
closest they get is saying the Hulk at
one hour 27 minutes and 47 seconds where
the soldiers are veering down the
streets urgently calling out to the
general much like this
in the street I repeat the Hulk is in
the street they do say each individual
part of the title because they say
incredible at 58-28 and the first time
they say Hulk is at 104.52 if you use a
little creativity you could have an
incredible wow it's like they
practically said it in the movie but
we're still counting that first time now
I had high hopes for this one because it
doesn't seem that hard to naturally work
the First Avenger into a sentence but
they never actually say it come on they
do however say Captain America and the
first time they say it is actually in
the song for Captain America's show
where he sells war bonds you feel like
busting out those show tunes time I'll
save it just hit the clip
now that's 15 minutes and 26 seconds
into the movie but like you said it'd be
super easy to work the First Avenger in
there here look you've been asleep
Captain America the worst Avenger for
almost 70 years missed opportunity Mark
but they learned their lesson for the
next one because they say the Winter
Soldier 52 34 sec
when Natasha's telling cat that she
knows who killed Fury most of the
intelligence Community doesn't believe
he exists the ones that do call him the
Winter Soldier they also say Captain
America at 1834 but they already got
their Spotlight so now it's our turn the
story of Captain America is one of Honor
bravery and sacrifice and although ours
is clearly Superior everything hers is
the more important to the title so
Winter Soldier will ring in at 52-34
Captain America Civil War really let me
down she
not only did
this let's get a ward 5812 but at this
point it just feels like a pity
so that means it's up to us to fix that
mistake they do say Captain America
though so maybe we should play that clip
first oh yeah okay all right Captain
America Mr Lang now here's how it should
have gone
[Music]
27 seconds they took them to say Captain
America now what movie showed them how
it's done what's that the Avengers had a
cool title drop it came when Nick Fury
was talking to the world Security
Council in 19 minutes and 59 seconds
into the movie The Avengers Initiative
Bing Bang Boom you got a title beautiful
music has always been such an important
part of the Guardians films and nerd
Riot's new awesome mix merch collection
has taken that idea and run with it
they've mashed up iconic album art with
the Guardians himself it's perfect gear
to wear opening weekend we're rocking
out in your daily life never mind
whether or not you grew up on grunge you
could get grunge Groot okay come on if
all the stars have you feeling more like
Ziggy Stardust then the Ziggy Star-Lord
T might be what you need if you like
Dark Side of the Moon then you'll love
this dark side of the Galaxy T shopping
at nerd Riot is one of the best ways to
support our Channel and in addition to
tons more Guardians merch you can find
merch inspired by the MCU Star Wars my
personal favorite all your favorite
fandoms guys we got it all here get your
hands on the merch you need head to nerd
riot.shop today join the riot over at
nerd riot.shop but please
shop peacefully oh they're so soft and
then the next one beefed it of course
Age of Ultron is such a good title into
robbers of that might just call for an
infinite no no no we're not there yet no
I'm sorry I'm so sorry now but they do
say The Avengers at 257. who gave the
order to attack as trucker is the
Avengers and they do say Ultron in 19
minutes artificial intelligence
this could be it Bruce this could be the
key to creating Ultron
whatever they did say the full title
it'd probably be something like this is
oh they got three for the price of one
on this one so wait which which do we go
with the Avengers or Ultron I think we
gotta go with Ultron as lame as it
sounds this may be almost plays pretty
high up there it's getting competitive
almost competitive enough to launch in
and okay yeah we can do it okay
Avengers Infinity war is another one
that uses every part of the title
without using the title itself it says
Avengers it's 1605. the Avengers broke
up War at 5309 and our personal favorite
Infinity it's 6 33. no other being
nay the nobility two wheel not one but
two Infinity Stones
but we can make a pretty convincing case
for how it could have been Infinity war
that one was just for us yeah we only
have so much fun to write these scripts
one for you one for me but we're using
Infinity 633 timestamp for this one and
then we have the final Avengers Avengers
end game and now they said the term end
game in both Age of Ultron and infinity
War so Preston doesn't this one Tommy oh
they don't say end gaming this one what
no they say Avengers 11 minutes and 41
seconds in well Tony is arguing with
Steve Brody is holding him back we're
The Avengers The Avengers not the pre
Avengers okay right you made your point
they don't say end game they don't say
end game we've got to fix it now that's
Avengers end game man I need some
Simplicity again I've got just the thing
Guardians of the Galaxy gave us that a
moment we were all craving kind of a
bummer hey because it was when Ronan had
taken down all the guardians but
regardless it clocks in at 140 106. your
Guardians the Galaxy
and we get another crisp title drop in
this one at 41-18 when yondu is talking
to the ravagers about why they should
take Rocket's deal instead of turning
him over the point is we ain't stupid
enough to help kill the Guardians of the
Galaxy technically the whole title
includes volume two though yeah I mean
can we work that and smooth them we
ain't stupid enough to help kill the
Guardians of the Galaxy
is better we've been running along let's
talk about it speaking of smoothies
butter Darren cross gives us our titular
moment in Ant-Man 11 minutes and 30
seconds into the movie as he's
antagonizing Hank with his past an ant
man
that's what they called you right ink
one of my personal favorites honestly
but how does the second movie live up
well Ant-Man has said one hour eight
minutes and 17 seconds into the movie
when it's been revealed to Cassie that
her dad has taken up the Ant-Man home
again so
how long have you been Ant-Man again but
even though they said the wasp in the
first movie they never say it in the one
that actually has the wasp in its title
luckily this one's easy to fit in they
call it molecular dissatman and the was
equilibrium
this one didn't even try sure they say
Ant-Man at 2306 when Janet's hornily
telling Hank to get on the alien horse
saddle up Ant-Man but they don't say the
wasp and they definitely don't say
quantumania hey Ant-Man if you're gonna
make up a word for your title how about
sticking to your guns for once anyway
here's where we put it we always were
a brother to me
I was
maybe the true prize was the quantum
media we found along the way now I know
my boy strange ain't gonna steer me
wrong he never could we gotta clean and
dare I say poisson Doctor Strange at 14
minutes and 18 seconds in when Doctor
Strange is meeting with a team of
doctors about his hands I'm sorry what
did you just call me along until like
strange those tissues are still healing
Multiverse and Menace though isn't as
successful the do get a doctor strange
in there before the wedding at four
minutes and 52 seconds
Dr West but the only other word they say
is Multiverse at three minutes and the
grand calculus on the Multiverse
your sacrifice is worth more than your
life which I
feel Multiverse of Madness much better
now you know black panther had to be one
of our favorites and the title came in
at an astounding 58 seconds into the
movie so without further wait should
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's fine as
long as you don't know yeah yeah the
warrior became
okay so we're not gonna touch it we're
nothing if not Texas but this movie
Nails it by saying both parts with black
panther at two minutes and seven seconds
and wakanda forever at two hours 16
minutes and 47 seconds
the largest gap so far but which one are
we gonna go with unfortunately for
wakanda forever we've got to follow the
pattern of going with the subtitle sorry
BP Oh Captain Marvel it's right there
and yet you just couldn't say it yeah
somewhat incredibly they never say
Captain Marvel in this movie I'm not
angry just disappointed the closest we
get is one hour 48 minutes and two
seconds into the movie when Danvers and
fury are washing dishes and then we are
delightfully treated to Samuel L
Jackson's rendition up wait a minute Mr
Postman Marvel sounds a lot better you
know like the Marvelettes
wait oh yes wait a minute Mr Postman but
as good as that
Nicholas Joseph Fury I'm with Captain
Marvel too
Captain Marvel doesn't say Captain
Marvel black wider doesn't say black
widow what are we doing here Hannah
please
come out of my rehydrated beans today I
don't know if I have the energy to act
this one out Tommy that's okay because
they technically say the word black at
3911 as Elena is describing her bike
which one's yours black brown seeds and
Widow at 45 minutes when they're talking
about the Red Room it moves location
constantly and every Widow is sedated on
entry and exit for maximum security so
we can just Mash those up and use our
imagination I mean you know we have to
go with a widow right we can't go with
her calling out the color of her bike
agreed now this one really took me by
surprise they do say Shang Chi when his
mom is talking to him in the beginning
at 8 minutes and 18 seconds but they
also say the fooling title right at the
beginning 46 seconds in you want to give
it a try nope sure eating
a freaking plus
eternals understood the assignment as
well just in a way more boring way 17
minutes and four seconds in we get the
titular line when Cersei is telling Dane
her backstory we're tunnels
a planet called Olympia I don't have
much more to say about that I give him
an e for f
and now we're back to Breaking the title
up with Spider-Man homecoming we get a
zesty Spider-Man that's 17 minutes and
13 seconds you're that Spider Guy on
YouTube right
okay okay Spider-Man do a flip and
actually for the first time the one
we're counting is actually earlier 10
minutes and 52 seconds you have a date
for homecoming the first one still gives
me Goosebumps though I mean the sheer
display of athleticism with that
backflip you want to do it again yeah
sir the Spider-Man movie started out so
strong but unfortunately it couldn't
last let me get a Spider-Man at 6 14
when Aunt May is speaking at an event
thank you all for coming out to support
those who have been displaced by the
blip and of course thanks to our very
own Spider-Man and out of context as it
is a home at 42-28 yeah so why are we
here speak for yourself
I'm home but sadly no fart no even
though it pains me I think we've got to
count home as the official time but come
on Marvel well I don't think we're in
Kansas anymore something squeeze it in
here what's right now they first
materialized on my Earth many years ago
we mobilized and fought them but with
each battle they grew got stronger
Spider-Man
far from home they are
at the beginning when they're playing
the recording of Mysterio from the last
movie the kicker is that it's at 20
seconds before the actual movie starts
I've managed to send the elemental back
through the dimensional Rift but I don't
think I'm gonna make it off this bridge
alive Spider-Man attacked me for some
reason but unfortunately it didn't learn
from its predecessor left out the term
no way home luckily we can Frankenstein
in no way at 101 57 and a home at 50 48
together to get the thing we all crave
no way home oh this one is one where I
want to count the time stamp of
Spider-Man so badly but I gotta say the
context of Aunt May talking about
sending the villains home is very
appropriate to the title yeah gotta
count home for this one so then Tommy
that's all our MCU movies what's our
winner the MCU movie that said the most
original and significant part of its
title the soonest was
in the legend of the ten rings at 46
seconds that's fast and the movie that
took the longest was Black Panther
wakanda forever clocking into two hours
16 minutes and 47 seconds if we were
counting any major part of the title
Spider-Man no way home would take it at
20 seconds but we are counting any major
part of the title rules are rules rules
are rules it feels right that it didn't
go to a movie where the title line was
actually from the previous movie you
know what I mean I do know what you mean
oh shoot Tommy we're almost late for a
joint dentist appointment oh God thank
you so much for watching could follow me
on Twitter at it's annabanston and me at
Tommy pecto and following subscribe to
new rockstars any rock stars for more
breakdowns of everything you love we're
out bye
[Music]
thank you